[Sharon] My name is Sharon
and I'm an alcoholic with
a splitting headache.
[All] Hi, Sharon.
[Gabe] My advice? Find
a reason to be here
that's bigger than you are.
[Sharon] I read about
this family in the paper.
I think this is it.
[Ashley] Dad.
We have a situation.
[Michelle] I wanna look
pretty for Mommy!
[Ed] Well, maybe just little
off the cheeks.
[Pastor Dave] God is here
with us right now
and we are here with you.
- Something about that little
girl without a Mama, sick.
And the family's bled dry
from all the hospital bills.
I think I'm supposed to help.
Hi! Sharon.
- Yes, ma'am.
- I just wanted to come
by and give you this.
[Barbara] I just made dinner
if you want to stay?
- Love to.
- Mom, what are you doing?
I've met this woman.
She's a mess.
- Perfect, she'll fit right in.
- $400,000 plus in
medical bills.
All three credit cards
maxed out
And your income's only
$3,600 a month?
- Yes, ma'am.
- That's not good, Ed.
- No, ma'am.
- I'm gonna put together
a press kit
for corporate donations,
that kind of thing.
Smile!
Girls, help your daddy out!
- Girls, wait.
(girls giggling)
- I've owned four
small businesses.
I'm good at plenty of things.
taking no for an answer
ain't one of 'em.
[Ashley] Daddy's in
over his head.
[Virginia] You're asking
us to reduce
the family's medical
bills due to hardship?
- No, I'm asking you
to erase them.
All of them.
Was that funny?
- Daddy!
My belly hurts.
- Oh, you wanna go on
an adventure?
- Mhmm.
(dramatic music)
[Dr. Ghorbani] Michelle will
need to fly 700 miles
to the children's hospital.
- Are you telling me we
need a plane now?
How exactly do you recommend
we get a plane, Doc?
- I'll get you a plane.
I promise.
We are going to save
this girl, you hear me?
- We're gonna need a
lot of shovels.
This is our last chance!
If we don't take it,
Michelle dies.
[Rose] How did it become your
responsibility to save her?
- 'Cause I'm here.
'Cause I can!
(dramatic music)